decisiones divididas en quito grupos a
favor y en contra el aborto se
manifestaron frente a la asamblea
nacional mientras los legisladores
debatían el proyecto de ley que
garantizaría la interrupción del
embarazo en caso de violación una
iniciativa que ha causado intensos
debates entre los parlamentarios el
punto de mayor discusión el número de
semanas en los que se podrá llevar a
cabo la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo las manifestantes pro aborto
pedían a los parlamentarios despenalizar
los procedimientos
[Música]
ah
mientras que las manifestantes anti
aborto rechazaron la ley es importante
que como joven necesitamos un poco de
las mentiras que se están promulgando
aquí en la asamblea respecto a los
derechos humanos a la defensa de los
derechos de las mujeres la corte
constitucional aprobó la despenalización
del aborto en caso de violación en abril
de 2021 y tiempo después la defensoría
del pueblo entregó el proyecto de ley
que estipula un margen de 20 semanas de
gestación para realizar la interrupción
del embarazo el de este jueves es el
segundo debate sobre la ley después de
que el primero se suspendiera en enero
se espera que la votación final del
proyecto se dé en aproximadamente 8 días
el ecuador es uno de los países de la
región con mayor tasa de embarazo
adolescente según el ministerio de salud
más de 3000 niñas son madres al año la
mayoría de los casos de embarazo en
menores son producto de la violación